die frage wird ja nicht alt die frage
wird seit jahren seit jahrzehnten immer
wieder diskutiert und es gibt immer
wieder traurige anlässe die diskussion
anstoßen
deutschland musste schon mehrere
amokläufe erleben und jetzt letztes
wochenende kamen diese grausam
nachrichten aus den usa
in den usa sind bei zwei angriffen mit
schusswaffen insgesamt 30 menschen
getötet worden
in dayton im bundesstaat ohio erschoss
ein mann neun menschen ehe er von der
polizei getötet wurde
wenige stunden zuvor hatte im
texanischen el paso ein täter 20
menschen erschossen und nach jedem
amoklauf und jedem shooting wird die
schuld immer wieder bei gewaltvollen
videospielen gesucht
dass das unerträgliche ausmachen von
gewaltverherrlichenden spielen im
internet auch eine schädliche wirkung um
die entwicklung gerade junge menschen
etwas kann kein vernünftiger mensch
bestreiten gleichzeitig hört man auch
immer wieder dass gewalt in
computerspielen zu realer gewalt führt
wurde noch nie nachgewiesen
beziehungsweise man muss sagen die eine
studie widerspricht jedes mal der
anderen studie ist das ist bei so einem
thema natürlich besonders frustrierend
dabei ist vieles nur deswegen so unklar
weil diese ganzen wissenschaftlichen
studien meistens zu verkürzt dargestellt
werden und das möchte ich ändern mit
diesem video also was sagt die
wissenschaft wirklich das klären wir
jetzt erstmal zum anfang würde ich gerne
ein paar argumente direkt vom tisch
räumen die uns in dieser debatte
definitiv nicht weiterbringen einfache
zusammenhänge
immer gewalt es gab schon immer waffen
nur mehr shootings sind erst seit 20
jahren häufig warum wegen videospielen
sagen die einen
das ist völliger quatsch lang ernannte
den ländern wie japan während viel mehr
videospiele gespielt und da gibt es viel
weniger gewalt also weder das eine noch
das andere beweist irgendwas sie die
sagen videospiele verursachen amokläufe
denn beides gibt es seit 20 jahren
das ist keine begründung denn in den
letzten 20 jahren hat sich sehr viel
getan videospiele und amokläufe sind nur
zwei von unzähligen veränderungen
deswegen kann man hier auch keine
ursachen ableiten und für diejenigen die
sagen videospiele führen nicht zu gewalt
stand japan spielt viel und ist
friedlich das ist auch keine begründung
denn der unterschied zwischen japan und
usa oder zwischen japan und deutschland
ist so riesig videospiele und
gewaltbereitschaft sind nur zwei
faktoren von unzähligen also auch hier
kann man keine begründung ableiten bzw
ausschließen und übrigens auch die
feststellung wir spielen eben zu und
gewalt allgemein nimmt ab stimmt zwar
ist aber alleine auch noch kein hinweis
dafür dass videospiele nichts mit gewalt
zu tun haben denn allgemein abnehmende
gewalt ist auch ein typisches indiz für
eine gesellschaft die sich weiter
entwickelt die zum beispiel wohlhabender
oder gebildeter wird außerdem die
westlichen gesellschaften wer noch immer
älter und ältere menschen sind selten
gewalttätig und senken so auch den
schnitt und solche effekte sind
möglicherweise viel größer so dass man
den einfluss von videospielen überhaupt
nicht durch so einen bloßen blick auf
eine statistik sehen kann also das sind
alles viel zu vereinfachte sichtweisen
die nicht der komplexen realität gerecht
werden und die jetzt so auch überhaupt
nicht weiterbringen deswegen lass uns
nicht mit solchen korrelation fallen
aufhalten sondern schauen wir uns mal
die wissenschaft die forschung an die
das ganze systematischer angeht fangen
wir an mit dieser studie aus dem jahr
2014 und einem sehr schönen beispiel für
schlechte mediale aufbereitung dieser
amerikanische morningshow lud einen
kinderpsychologen ein um über die studie
zu sprechen die zu dem schluss kommt ja
videospiele machen aggressiv genauer
gesagt häufiges spielen gewalt voller
videospiele führte zu aggressiveren
doch alle der hochspringt einen sehr
starken einwand nämlich ist gäbe doch
keinen wissenschaftlich nachgewiesenen
zusammenhang zwischen videospielen und
realer gewalt und darauf antwortete
experte genau das ist der knackpunkt wir
sprechen hier von aggressiven gedanken
und nicht von aggressiven taten und wir
können nicht vorschnell wird genau dort
abgebrochen sendezeit vorbei so viel zu
verkürzen in den medien aber greifen wir
das mal auf den er trägt eine der
knackpunkte in dieser frage ist wie viel
hat das was in diesen studien gemessen
wird wirklich mit realer gewalt zu tun
dazu müssen wir erst mal wissen was in
dieser studie genau gemessen wurde
und ich werde nicht müde es wiederholen
wissenschaftliche ergebnisse sind
wertlos solange ihr nicht nachvollziehen
könnt wie diese ergebnisse entstanden
sind und diese infos die findet ihr in
einer wissenschaftlichen
veröffentlichung unter methods also
methoden hier also die methoden der
besagten studie erst mal die daten für
diese studie kommen aus befragungen von
kindern und jugendlichen
es gibt halt nun mal nicht für alles
physikalische messmethoden manchmal ist
eine befragung das beste tool das man
hat und natürlich ist so eine
wissenschaftliche befragung
systematischer durchgeführt als jetzt
eine nicht wissenschaftliche oben frage
aber trotzdem sind diese daten nur dann
wirklich verlässlich wenn wir davon
ausgehen dass diese kinder und
jugendliche sich selbst gut und ehrlich
einschätzen können das hat das ist schon
die erste wichtige methodische info für
uns die uns sagt vorsicht bei der
interpretation dieser daten das gute ist
die teilnehmer wurden mehrmals befragt
über einen längeren zeitraum also hier
drei jahre und so eine studie bei der
man die teilnehmer über einen längeren
zeitraum beobachtet nennt man
longitudinal studie oder
längsschnittstudie wenn wir stattdessen
nur zu einem zeitpunkt befragen und
dabei kommt zum beispiel auch kinder die
viele videospiele spielen sind auch
gewalttätiger
dann wissen wir immer noch nicht in
welche richtung die kausalität verläuft
also machen die videospiele die kinder
gewalttätig oder greifen gewalttätige
kinder häufiger zu videospielen
einer longitudinal studie einer
längsschnittstudie hingegen gibt es den
vorteil dass ich entwicklungen
beobachten kann nur mal als beispiel
sagen wir in so einer längsschnittstudie
stellte fest dass eine gruppe von
teilnehmern im laufe dieser drei jahre
zunehmend häufig videospiele spielt und
sie werden zeitlich verzögert auch immer
aggressiver dann ist das ein hinweis auf
einen kausalen zusammenhang also
wirklich darauf dass videospiele
aggressionen auslösen
für unser methodisches verständnis
bedeutet dass längsschnittstudien
liefern uns mehr als nur
zusammenhanglose korrelation aber die
aussagekraft zu einer studie ist auch
abhängig von der teilnehmerzahl hier
wurden über 3000 kinder und jugendliche
befragt das ist sehr solide
teilnehmerzahlen in den tausenden sind
ein gutes methodisches zeichen ok bleibt
jetzt noch die frage was genau wurde
hier befragt schauen wir uns das noch an
erstens gaming rapids also welche
videospiele spielen die teilnehmer und
wie häufig und dann wurden noch vier
weitere sachen befragt die
möglicherweise mit diesen gaming rapids
zusammenhängen aggressives verhalten
also haben die kids zum beispiel häufig
schon mal jemanden geschlagen aggressive
gedanken hier mussten die kinder
jugendliche fragen beantworten wie zum
beispiel stell dir vor ein junger
beleidigt einen anderen jungen namens
john findest du es gerechtfertigt wenn
john den anderen jungen schlägt oder
stellst du dir manchmal vor jemandem die
du nicht magst wehzutun dann noch
empathie also einfühlvermögen und der
einfluss der eltern also haben die
eltern ein strenges auge auf die
videospiele oder eher nicht und so
weiter so jetzt da wir endlich wissen
wie und was alles gemessen wurde gehen
wir jetzt noch mal zurück zu den
ergebnissen und in vier befragten sachen
die möglicherweise im videospiel konsum
zusammen hängen nämlich aggressives
verhalten aggressive gedanken empathie
und der einfluss der eltern fahren diese
studie nur einen haupt zusammenhang
nämlich gewaltvolle videospiele führen
zu aggressiven gedanken aber aggressive
gedanken führen nicht automatisch zu
aggressivem verhalten oder gar gewalt
ich meine
jeder von uns hat sich doch schon mal
irgendwann gedacht diesen idioten würde
ich mal gerne auf die nase hauen
ich hab sowas bestimmt schon mal gedacht
aber habe ich schon mal wirklich
niemanden auf die nase gehauen nein denn
ich war ja nicht lächerlich
nein denn natürlich nur weil ich mal
einen gewalttätigen gedanken hegel bin
ich noch lange kein gewalttätiger mensch
und ich habe diese studie ausgewählt
weil sie exemplarisch ist für ein
häufiges missverständnis nämlich in
vielen studien werden nur aggressive
gedanken beobachtet und nicht
aggressives verhalten und trotzdem
werden diese beiden dinge häufig
vermischt oder ausgetauscht
denn über diese studien gesprochen wird
und noch etwas geht in dieser diskussion
oft unter gewalt hat viele ursachen
unser verhalten und unsere taten werden
von sehr vielen dingen beeinflusst von
außen zählen da medien und videospiele
sicherlich auch dazu aber es gibt
natürlich auch noch unsere mitmenschen
und die familien und es gibt auch noch
körperliche faktoren wie zum beispiel
die psychische gesundheit oder
genetische dispositionen in meinem video
über psychopathie habe ich da zum
beispiel über das vorgehen gesprochen
die anzahl der verschiedenen
risikofaktoren für gewalt ist nicht nur
riesig sondern viele dieser faktoren
beeinflussen sich auch gegenseitig und
mit dem hinterkopf
schauen wir uns nochmal die studie von
nebenan hier wurden offenbar keine
befragung durchgeführt zu sagen wie
soziales umfeld oder eventuelle gewalt
und der familie bildung und so weiter
das heißt all diese einflussfaktoren die
sicherlich einen großen einfluss haben
werden in dieser auswertung nicht
beachtet anders machte es da zum
beispiel diese studie aus dem jahr 2016
über 9000 jugendliche wurden befragt und
es ergab sich ein zusammenhang zwischen
videospielen und aggressivem verhalten
also wirklich behalten nicht gedanken
zum beispiel das schlagen andere person
mit der absicht ihnen wehzutun aber
jetzt schauten sich die forscher auch an
was für ein soziales und familiäres
umfeld diese jugendlichen hatten sie
eine gute beziehung zu ihren eltern
das etwa gewalt zu hause ist die
forscher diese faktoren mit einbezogen
in ihrer auswertung
das heißt nur teilnehmer verglichen mit
einem ähnlichen sozialen und familiären
umfeld dann verschwand der zusammenhang
zwischen videospielen und gewalt hier
kommen die forscher also zu dem schluss
soziale und familiäre faktoren sind
ausschlaggebend für gewaltvolle
essverhalten und nicht video spielt es
ist nicht die einzige studie die keinen
zusammenhang findet zwischen videospiele
und gewalt aber es gibt auch nicht
wenige studien die einen zusammenhang
sehen nur ist der effekt nie
erschreckend groß also die tech größen
schwanken zwischen sehr klein und ich
sag mal mittel klein und das ist auch
wichtig für uns zu wissen denn studien
die sich auf den ersten blick völlig
widersprechen also angesagt wie ihr
spiel ist gefährlich die andere sagt wie
die späte sind harmlos die linien
wirklichkeit gar nicht so weit
auseinander weil die effekte meistens
klein sind also sie liegen meistens
ziemlich nah bei der mitte das ist ja
eigentlich nicht verwunderlich denn in
der realität tritt ein etwaiger einfluss
von videospielen ja immer gleichzeitig
auf mit einer reihe von anderen
einflüssen und das ist ein
grundsätzlicher nachteil ein
methodischer nachteil solcher
längsschnittstudien man kann nicht einen
einzelnen einfluss isoliert betrachten
deswegen gibt es auch noch
laborexperimente ich kann mir
versuchsteilnehmer einlagen ins labor
und mache eine testgruppe a und eine
kontrollgruppe p und die beiden gruppen
sind sich sehr ähnlich die agieren auch
unter genau denselben bedingungen nur
die testgruppe die lasse ich ein gewalt
vor das videospiel spielen test gruppe b
nicht und dann vergleich der beiden
gruppen und schaue ob gruppe a
vielleicht aggressiver ist als kopie und
wenn das der fall ist dann kann ich geht
unterschied ganz klar auf das
gewaltvolle videospiel zurückführen
doch auch im labor gilt auch hier kann
man meistens nur aggressive gedanken
messen und nicht aggressives verhalten
keine aggressiven taten warum
na ja weil es nicht zu verantworten und
nicht ethisch vertretbar ist menschen
für ein experiment zu gewaltvollen taten
zu animieren also um sie dürfen
natürlich niemand anderem auch schaden
zufügen was man stattdessen man versucht
aggressionen indirekt zu messen
und das ist sehr mäßig warum man im
labor aggressionen nicht wirklich messen
kann
machen wir doch mal einen test mit euch
ich zeige euch gleich ein
unvollständiges wort das ihr
vervollständigen soll er sagt einfach
das erste wort das euch in den sinn
kommt
freunde der sonne beruhigt euch mal alle
die hier sofort eine gewalt gedacht
haben friedliebende leute denken
natürlich an gehalt also fremde leute
die auch pleite sind
ihr seht wo das problem liegt oder die
meisten von euch haben gerade an gewalt
gedacht weil wir in diesem video schon
die ganze zeit über gewalt sprechen und
ihr dadurch geprellt wurde das heißt
noch lange nicht dass ihr gewaltvolle
gedanken habt generell oder dass dieses
video euch aggressiv macht zumindest
hoffe ich das doch anderes beispiel ist
die vervollständigung dieses wortes denn
man könnte das mit explode oder explorer
vervollständigen aber wenn man gerade
ein videospiel gespielt hatte wo
explosionen stattfinden dann ist es blöd
einfach ein naheliegendes wort und noch
lange kein hinweis darauf dass man
ernsthaft aggressive gedanken hegt und
auch warum uns zu erinnern was ich die
frage ist um von so etwas auf einen
amoklauf zu schließen
das ist völlig absurd aber es gibt auch
noch andere tests da wäre zum beispiel
das sogenannte hotspur mit 1
hier sollen die teilnehmer das essen
einer anderen person mit hot socks
würzen also mit scharfer soße obwohl
diese andere person scharfes essen nicht
mag
und je mehr haut source man benutzt um
diese andere person zu quälen desto
aggressiver widmann eingestuft also das
ist ein test der wirklich so im labor
gemacht wird sich das jetzt erst mal so
stehen
ich erzähle ich noch einen zweiten test
nämlich ich nenne jetzt mal den lärm
strafen test fachbegriff ist eigentlich
competitive reaction time task hier
werden die teilnehmer in dem glauben
gehalten dass sie ein computerspiel
gegen eine andere person im nebenraum
spielen und gegen diese personen müssen
sie besser abschneiden in reaktionstests
wenn sie gewinnen dürfen sie die andere
person bestrafen und zwar mit einem
lauten unangenehm geräusch über deren
kopfhörer
die laute man dieses straff geräusch für
den anderen wählt desto aggressiver wird
man bewertet die anderen personen im
nebenraum gibt es in wirklichkeit gar
nicht also das nicht wirklich jemand
durch laute geräusche bestraft wird
sorry ich bin offensichtlich eine ganz
aggressiver mensch wie soll ich sagen
ihr könnt euch jetzt auch selbst
überlegen wie verlässlich solche tests
sind um gewalt volles verhalten voraus
zu sagen also nicht umsonst ist die
aussagekraft dieser test hoch umstritten
und das ist noch nicht das einzige
problem mit den laborexperimenten töten
distanzen in einem laborexperiment
sollten die tests und die kontrollgruppe
so ähnlich wie möglich sein damit wir
sie auch gut vergleichen können wenn die
testgruppe ein gewalt volles videospiel
spielt und die kontrollgruppe ein nicht
gewalt tolles spiel
dann sollten die beiden spiele aber mit
ausnahme des faktors gewalt trotzdem so
ähnlich wie möglich sein denn weiß ich
wenn ich jetzt counter strike gegen
kenny crashtest dann hat counter strike
sicher mehr gewalt aber das spiel ist
sicherlich auch frustrierend da ist
kenny goss und allein das könnte zu mehr
aggressiven zeichen führen
trotzdem gibt es laborstudien die das
nichtbeachten ein extremfall ist diese
studie hier in der freunde setzt euch
ernsthaft mortal kombat gegen
dancedancerevolution getestet wurde
es gibt auch methodisch starke studien
die auf diese vergleichbarkeit achten in
dieser studie zum beispiel wurde das
spiel an return immens so modifiziert
dass es eine vergleichbare nicht
gewaltvolle version für die
kontrollgruppe gab er wurde zum beispiel
die waffe durch eine art tennisball
läuft kann ersetzt und werden andere
spieler erschossen wurde dann gab es
keinen grafischen tod mit blut und so
weiter sondern die figur wurde dann
einfach transparent
in einer anderen studie diesmal die
beiden gruppen vergleichbare versionen
des spiels theme for jazz spielen nur
einmal mit flammenwerfern und reimer mit
rainbow kanonen und in beiden studien
mit dieser methodischen sorgfalt fanden
die forscher keinen zu
zusammenhang zwischen der gewalt im
spiel und aggressiven zeichen oder
aggressiven getan
das deutet darauf hin dass aggressive
gedanken nicht auf die gewalt im spiel
zurück zu führen sind sondern
möglicherweise auf andere unterschied im
spiel so er ist jetzt sehr viel mehr
wird es ein forschungsbereich aber
verwirrend ist das ganze vielleicht
trotzdem noch ein bisschen deswegen lass
uns mal ein strich ziehen sind
videospiele jetzt gefährlich oder
harmlos videospiele und medienkonsum
allgemein haben sicherlich einen breiten
und langfristigen einfluss auf uns als
gesellschaft die einfluss- und
videospiele unseren sozialen umgang
miteinander
oder wie verarbeiten wir bestimmte
spiele oder medien eigentlich also die
sind ja keine maschinen die irgend den
puls kriegen und dann wie die lemminge
handeln oder sollten kinder und
jugendliche gewalt vor dem spiel spielen
das sind alles legitime und spannende
forschungsfragen überhaupt finde ich
dass wir aus ethischen moralischen
gründen mehr diskutieren sollten darüber
wie wir mit gewalt in videospielen oder
medien umgehen gerade für kinder und
jugendliche aber zu behaupten dass es
eine wissenschaftliche beweislage gäbe
für irgend welche praktischen
konsequenzen also für regulierung von
videospielen
das ist schlichtweg falsch und vor allem
die frage machen videospiele amokläufer
ist eine frage die kein seriöser
wissenschaftler ernst nimmt sondern
leider nur die medien
videospiele sind keine ursache für
amokläufe wenn aber jemand fantasien
hegt einen amoklauf durchzuführen
denn können videospiele gewalt wurde
videospiele natürlich dazu beitragen
aber dazu zählen auch gewaltvolle filme
dazu zählt auch reale gewalt wie sie in
den nachrichten berichtet wird also nein
videospiele waren keine ursache für die
kürzlichen shootings in el paso und
selten
diese behauptung ist so absurd verkürzt
was nach diesem video hoffentlich klar
sein sollte und es ist frustrierend dass
so viele politiker gibt die das entweder
nicht wissen oder bewusst ignorieren es
ärgert mich so sehr dass die nsa also
die amerikanische waffenlobby mit diesem
blöden pseudo argument videospiele davon
ablenken kann dass man natürlich für
jeden amoklauf erst mal fakten woche
braucht auch in deutschland ist es
schädlich wenn wir uns von den wirklich
wichtigen sachen ablegen
denn wenn angehörige von gewaltopfern
fragen warum wenn wir uns fragen wie
können wir das in zukunft verhindern
dann gibt es ein paar ganz wichtige
stellschrauben die gewalt reduzieren
nämlich bessere psychische gesundheit
bessere bildung und die bekämpfung von
armut
hier ist der zusammenhang mit gewalt
wissenschaftlich sehr gut nachgewiesen
das sind die probleme die wir lösen
müssen aber klar wie die spiele zu
verbieten wäre ja so viel einfacher noch
keine lösung nicht interessiert sehr was
ihr zu diesem thema denkt deswegen
schreibt das gerne in die kommentare
natürlich könnt ihr auch immer gerne
themenvorschläge für zukünftige videos
einreichen die lese ich auch sehr gerne
und zum schluss noch etwas ganz anderes
nämlich vielen wirklich herzlichen dank
für all eure liegen glückwünsche unter
dem letzten video und auch bei instagram
ich habe mich sehr gefreut und matthias
auch und ich spreche jetzt einfach mal
fürs baby wenn ich sage das baby auch
ich kann mich nicht bei allen persönlich
bedeuten deswegen versuche ich das jetzt
auf diesem weg wirklich vielen lieben
dank ganz ganz viele kekse aller von
euch wie sehen uns nächste woche und bis
dahin plötzlicher